welcome to Hannity tonight there is a
clear front-runner in the extreme
radical Democratic Socialist Party and
yep that 78 year old curmudgeon devout
Soviet style socialist you know the guy
that took a honeymoon in the former
Soviet Union that guy the Democratic
Party is in a state of rooms tonight the
moderates huh they are non-existent long
gone pragmatic centrist politicians
there's not even room for Joe Lieberman
any longer in this Democratic Party so
radical extreme and yes socialism that
would destroy the great American
prosperity that we've now experienced
for the last three years last night
Bernie Sanders huge victory in New
Hampshire and now according to brand new
polls Bernie Sanders is leading the
Democratic field with a massive edge
headed into Super Tuesday states now
there's no other way to put this if this
guy is elected well pretty much there
are all just variations of him these
policies would destroy the economy of
this country let's see a 94 trillion
dollar new Green Deal in 10 years but
will they take in four four and a half
trillion a year Oh in the same 10-year
period fifty-two trillion Medicare for
all
the government literally Oh full
socialism they would control the means
of production for thousands of
businesses across America oh and take
over the energy sector for the first
time in 75 years we are energy
independent taxes for every American
he's running on this platform we are
going to raise your taxes maybe double
or triple them and if you saved enough
money after we taxed you the first time
will legalize stealing more of it and
when you die you're gonna give us
another chunk of your money oh and we're
gonna lose jobs because of his extreme
environmental policies that's the
platform your bank accounts will be
slapped with the wealth tax the IRS
might even confiscate any income over a
certain undisclosed amount
Bernie's standing by the idea of maximum
income okay if you earn it in three
months
why would you bother working another day
of the year and creating jobs for other
Americans or at least that's what he
said publicly and that is we what he is
advocated for and standing by by
all accounts even some Democrats
prominent Democrats see this is a
disaster for their party look at this
new Monmouth University poll roughly
two-thirds of voters believe President
Trump will be re-elected me I'm Irish I
always think something bad is gonna
happen any second you know what that
means don't count on it
the only way you get there is if you
show up and vote in 266 days new Gallup
poll showing 53% of Americans would not
vote for a socialist why that's not 99
percent I don't know not exactly cause
to celebration that means we have a
fight on our hands in terms of the
future and direction of the country 43%
of Americans would vote for a socialist
that's pretty scary you can't take
anything for granted
ultimately the only poll that will
matter as I said in 265 days and
anything is possible for example look at
quid and Pro and quo and Joe and zero
experience hunter Joe thought he was
gonna waltz right into the Democratic
nomination riding on Barack Obama's
coattails the entire way oh but they did
give us 13 million more Americans on
food stamps 8 million more in poverty in
the lowest labor participation rate
since the 70s
yeah great record when they gave the
mullahs in Iran a hundred and fifty
billion in cash you know the currency as
they chant death to America Wow want to
do that again
now his campaign is clearly on life
support a fourth place finish in Iowa a
disastrous fifth place finish in New
Hampshire he ran out of town didn't even
say goodbye to his supporters he phoned
that any facetimed it by the way now a
head of South Carolina his support among
african-american voters a key part of
the Democratic coalition and base it is
sliding unmitigated disaster and
honestly it's not really shocking for
months his campaign has been plagued
with serious corruption allegations out
of Ukraine China and elsewhere few days
ago what politician would ever do this
calling a young female voter 21 years
old as she said she felt humiliated a
lying dog faced pony soldier hello now
before that he called another voter a
damn liar and another one fat counts him
to a push-up competition and then it was
Joe 303 304
a second time his speeches is barely
coherent last night South Carolina no
exception we've got the video evidence
let's go to the videotape it is
important that I went Nevada I'm spoken
but look we need to hear from Nevada and
South Carolina and Super Tuesday states
and beyond okay what you saw mixing up
states pretty mild gap by 303 300 with
this campaign now on life support let's
take one more walk down a little memory
lane shall we
but some of Biden's finest moments as a
public figure and it's getting worse
take a look his mama lived in in Long
Island for ten years or so god rest her
soul and although she's wait your mom
still your mom's still alive is your dad
passed god bless her soul Chuck Graham
state senators here Chuck
stand up Chuck let him see it Oh God
love you what am I talking about a man
who will be the next president the
United States Barack America Delaware
the largest growth of population is
Indian oh there's a Democratic Party
frontrunner and now by the way his
campaign is circling the drain but he's
not giving up hope just today Biden
rolling out a brand new low-budget ad
proclaiming he's just getting started
fourth place fifth place let's try for
six take a look we don't feel no ways
tired we've come too far from where we
started
nobody told me the road would be easy
and I don't believe he brought me to
this far to stop now you know like
what's going on in this country only one
thing to do work together we can and
will win let's take back this country
now ah that's not plagiarism again is it
anyway who did it better Joe or Hillary
at least quid pro quo Joe can take some
comfort knowing he wasn't the only big
loser in New Hampshire yet serial liar
fellow socialist Elizabeth Warren also
had a very poor showing now keep in mind
New Hampshire borders her home state of
Massachusetts where most of the
population lives Warren has virtually no
path now to victory now she is shifting
her last remaining campaign funds to
make one last stand this time in Nevada
and tonight it is unclear just who's
gonna drop out of the Democratic race
next there's something to bet on one
thing is certain socialist Bernie
Sanders is not going anywhere he's
building a large coalition of radical
dedicated Democratic voters and now one
of his top advisors is even calling for
Mike Bloomberg to drop out of the race
Mike's got this great campaign going he
pays for ads and hides and nobody ever
sees them or gets to ask him a question
Wow great way slick marketing campaign
now after new video emerged this week
showing Bloomberg's true feelings about
minorities 2013 that's right
Bloomberg saying white people were being
stopped too much by police minorities
too little and he said in 2015 the only
way to prevent this crime was to throw
minority kids up police throw up against
the wall and frisk them and by the way
then he said all he put the word all in
there he put all of the police at
minority neighborhoods not some all of
them in New York because that's where
all the crime is really I live in New
York and I could tell you that's not
true now despite these disturbing
comments Bloomberg he'll spend money
he's not going anywhere we sent our own
Lawrence Jones to New York City to see
what many Mikes former constituents
think about their old mayor of course
the billionaire former Republican in
name only is the Democratic
establishments plan B
biden's implosion and as we speak it
appears a panicked establishment
Democratic Party is exploring ways yeah
it looks like they may want to rig the
election again against Bernie Sanders
may be in favor of Bloomberg or whoever
else else's left standing to try and buy
the nomination in Bloomberg's case that
would include new measures that could
give super-delegates
Oh a vote on the first ballot the right
to block Bernie
yep out of convention now whatever
happens in the coming weeks and months
the state of the Democratic parties
never been worse still let me emphasize
again anything can happen I take nothing
for granted 265 days well I would say
we're at a tipping point America on the
brink